let's review a bit of what we learned in
the last video if i have some linear
transformation it's a mapping
from rn to rn and if we're dealing with
standard coordinates that transformation
applied to some vector x in standard
coordinates will be equal to the matrix
a times x
so let me write this down if we are
dealing with the standard coordinates
standard
standard coordinates
coordinates
so i have x in standard coordinates if i
apply the transformation that is
equivalent to multiplying x by
a
then i if i multiply x by a then i'm
going to get the transformation of x
i'm going to get the transformation of x
in standard coordinates this is a world
that we're very very familiar with
now let's say that we have an alternate
basis to rn
so let's say that
b
let's say b is equal to v 1
v 2
all the way to v n so it has n linearly
independent vectors let's say b is
a
basis
for
rn so it's a basis for rn but it's the
non-standard basis these aren't just our
standard basis vectors so b is a basis
for rn and let's say
let's say that c
c which is just has these guys as its
column vectors c is v1 v2 all the way to
vn
is the change of basis matrix
change of basis
matrix matrix for
this basis for the basis b
now we've learned we've seen this
several times already that if i have if
i have some vector x
in rn represented in b coordinates
or in coordinates with respect to b i
can multiply it by the change of basis
matrix and then i'll get just the
standard coordinates for x or if you
multiply both sides of this equation by
c inverse you can get that if i start
with the standard
coordinates for x i can multiply it by c
inverse and then i could get the v
coordinates for x or the alternate
non-standard coordinates for x so the
but we've seen both of these before so
let's apply that to this little diagram
here so if i want to get x and if i
wanted to write it in non-standard
coordinates what do i do well if i have
x and if i want to write it so if i have
x let me go right here
so if i have x
what do i multiply it by if i want to go
to non-standard coordinates well i
multiply it by c inverse
if i multiply it by c inverse you can
whatever i write next to this line you
can say what do you have to multiply
what what matrix you have to multiply by
to get to the other endpoint on your
line so i multiply x by c inverse
then i get
the v coordinates
then i get the b coordinates for x so
these are
let's see coordinates coordinates
with
respect
with respect to
b i could do the same thing here with
the transformation of x this is just the
standard representation of the
transformation of x
so i could multiply it by c inverse if
we want to go in that direction and then
we're going to get the transformation of
x we're going to get the transformation
of x
represented in b coordinates
now in the last video what we saw is hey
why go you know why do these separately
maybe there is some matrix and we found
out what it is maybe there's some matrix
d
that if we multiply this guy
times it i can go straight from the b
coordinates of x to the b coordinate of
the transformation of x
and we said that is matrix d and in that
last video we showed that d can be
represented by a actually you could go
around the circle and re-derive it if
you like but we found out that let me
write it in another color
that d
is equal to
c inverse
times a times c
now this is all a review of everything
that we learned in the last video
hopefully it clarified things up a
little bit it's nice to just realize
that these are just alternate ways of
doing the same thing both of these are
the transformation or when you go from
you multiply by a you're applying the
same transformations when you multiply
by d you're just doing it in a different
coordinate system different coordinate
systems are just different ways of
representing the same vector
this and this are same labels for the
are different labels for the same vector
this and this are different labels for
the same vector so these are both
performing the transformation t
now this was a relation we got in the
last video that if you give us if you if
we have our change of basis matrix we
have its inverse and we have just our
our standard basics linear trend our
standard basis linear transformation
matrix we're able to get this let's see
if we can go the other way if we have d
can we solve for a
well if you multiply both sides of this
equation on the right by c inverse you
get
d c inverse is equal to c inverse a c
c inverse i just put a c inverse on the
right hand side of both sides of this
equation this is going to be the
identity matrix so we can ignore it and
then let's multiply both sides on the
left by c so then you get c d c inverse
is equal to c c inverse a
and this is going to be the identity
matrix and then you're left with a is
equal to c times d
c inverse which is another interesting
result it's another thing to put in our
toolkit now everything i've been doing
has been fairly abstract let's actually
apply some of these principles with a
real concrete example
so let's say
that i have a transformation t
let's say i have a transformation t
i'll keep these guys around just because
they might be useful that is a mapping
from r2
to r2 and let's say that the
transformation matrix for t so let's say
that t
of x in standard coordinates is equal to
the matrix
3 2
minus 2
minus 2 times x so this is in the
example we just said this would be
our transformation matrix with respect
to the standard basis and we could call
that a right there now let's say we have
some alternate basis let's say we have
some alternate basis
so alternate
alternate
r2 basis
let's say let's call that b because
we've been calling it b so far and let's
say this alternate r two basis
the vectors one two
and
and two one
so let's see given this alternate basis
whether we can come up for a
transformation matrix in that coordinate
world so what we're looking for
we're looking for
some matrix d
looking for a matrix d
such that if i apply my transformation
to x in b coordinates so if i apply it
to x
in v coordinates or in coordinates with
respect to this alternate basis
it should be equal to
this matrix this matrix it should be
equal to
d
times x
x in the b coordinates
so this is what i'm looking for i'm
looking for that or if we go back to our
diagram
i'm looking for that you give me x and b
coordinates and i and you multiply it by
d and i'm going to give you the
transformation of x and b coordinates
now just applying it to this concrete
example here
all we we have this formula right here
this is a formula for d which we proved
in the last video so we have to figure
out c inverse so what is
the change of basis matrix for b let me
do it down i want to leave this up here
so let me
so change
change of basis
matrix
matrix for b is just going to be let's
just call it c and it's going to be
the basis vectors for b's within the
column so 1 2 and 2 1
and then we're going to want to figure
out its inverse so let's figure out its
determinant first so the determinant of
c is equal to 1 times one minus two
times two so one minus four is minus
three and so c
inverse is going to be equal to one over
the determinant
one over minus three or minus one thirds
times we switch these two guys so we
switch the one and the one and then we
make these two guys negative
minus two minus two that is c inverse
so d
this d this d vector right here is going
to be equal to c inverse times a
times the transformation matrix with
respect to the standard basis times c so
let me write it down here just because
let me write it
so d
the d that we're looking for
d is going to be equal to c inverse
times a
times c
which is equal to c inverse is minus 1 3
times 1 minus 2 minus 2 1
times
a
let me do this in a different color i
like to switch colors so c inverse times
a a is right there so times
3 minus 2 2
minus 2
times c c is right there i'll do it in
yellow
times c which is 1 2
and then 2 1. so let's do this piece by
piece let's work through this so what is
this piece going to be equal to we have
a 2 by 2 times a 2 by 2 that's going to
give us another
2 by 2 matrix
so this first term right here will be 3
times 1 plus minus 2 times 2. so 3
3 minus 4 so it's going to be minus 1
right 3 times 1 plus minus 2 times 2
right it's minus 1. then you have 3
times 2 which is 6
minus 2 right minus 2 times 1 so that is
4 right 3 times 2 minus 2 is 4
and then when you go down here 2 times 1
minus two times two that's two minus
four that's minus two
and then two times two is four
minus two times one so four minus two is
just two
so our matrix d is going to be equal to
minus one 3 times this guy 1 minus 2
minus 2 1
times this guy which was just the
product of those two matrices
now let's figure out what this is if i
take the product of these two guys it's
going to be another 2 by 2 matrix
so of one times minus one
one times minus one which is minus one
plus minus two times minus two
minus two times minus two so let me make
sure so one times minus one minus two
times minus 2 is 4 and then 1 times
minus 1 is minus 1 so it's going to be 3
and then we have and then we go to the
next term we have 1 times 4
plus minus 2
times two so that's four minus
four which is zero and then we have
minus two times minus one which is two
plus one times minus two so that is zero
and then finally we have minus two times
four which is minus eight
right minus two times four is minus
eight plus one times two so minus eight
minus two times four is minus eight plus
two is minus six and all of that times
minus one third
so this is going to be equal to three
times minus one third is minus one
zero and then zero minus six times minus
one third is
is 2. so this is so d is now our
transformation matrix
is now our transformation matrix with
respect to the basis b with respect to
the basis b so we were able to figure it
out just applying this formula here
now
what happens let's actually do it with
some actually i'll save that for the
next video where we actually show that
it works that it we can actually take
some vectors
we can actually take some vectors x
apply the transformation or apply the
change of coordinates to get to this and
then apply d and then maybe we could go
up that way multiply by c to get the
transformation it's going to be
equivalent to a i'll do that in the next
video